I've been working with documents are so
long I don't have to school them and
what's keyboarding is or how to
represent it well so working together as
pretty serious you know working on a pro
skater game there's a lot of history
behind it the pressure to live up to the
20 hot franchise is because of that it's
a franchise that people have loved and
played for years I grew up having my dad
always have him around and he would
always let me play them before they came
out before I was in the first tony hawk
game Alex and I I used to play the games
all the time when I was a kid even
before I start skating and start playing
tony hawk games with my builder in my
friends as a kid I thought was my game
it was I would come home little Tony off
and you know coming in here I get to be
the guy that makes those worlds longtime
fans of the pro skater series where they
get into the game they'll see you know
the hallmarks of the games incredible
combos that you can do great lines to
grind all of the key mechanics of a pro
skater are all returning and they're so
you know people who are longtime fans
don't know instantly how to play it we
really looked at you know the pro skater
series and all the different gameplay
mechanics they had and we started
picking out like it'd be very
interesting if we decide to add like a
new unique kind of gameplay mechanic
into each level so one of the biggest
ones that we did was basically slamming
down when you all the up you hit the
slam button and you can instantly slam
down and grind on any surface it's a
very simple mechanic but really changes
the pace of the game itself in too many
ways a speeds things up
I think our use of real-life locations
is going to appeal to the hardcore skate
film but we create a park mode I think
that is when to bring the video game
community in in a very big way we're
always trying to create that sandbox
field of I'm creating a playground for
people to play levels and it's so much
fun to do a designer like let's give
that experience to the players so the
course creator is something that you
know allows a fan to go into a template
based on other levels that are already
in pro skater 5 and just have a slew of
skate props available to them you can
put it online other people can download
it you can vote them to be the best and
you know create your own challenges
within those levels that's a whole new
level of control that we haven't had
before
so with the online multiplayer you're
going to have an online state community
sort of it really is about a skate park
experience so I'm going to go select a
level to play in I'm the skating around
doing objectives as I want to but with
that level there's the other players
doing the same as I think and so it's
it's not a single player campaign
anymore it's a community it's cool to
have skate kids playing the game and
feel like they're part of the community
it's a virtual oasis our goal was make a
pro skater game 4 2015 and so that's
we've done with online features create a
park system and then all the fun stuff
that was from pro skaters that people
loved or bring it to this game
you